we can go to central London where we're
joined by the house secretary Matt
Hancock thank you very much for being
with us this morning mr. Hancock so it's
the morning after Super Saturday how do
you think it went well I think that from
what I've seen although there's some
pictures to the country very very
largely people have acted responsibly
and this this balanced message is so
important people should enjoy summer
safely and of course the emphasis is
both on enjoy and safely
we of course everybody knows that we're
doing everything we can to get to get
back to normal but only to do that where
it's safe to do so so so overall I'm
pleased with what happened yesterday it
was really good to see people out and
about and largely very largely social
distancing so you say that you're
pleased with what happened one person
who's rather less pleased is John apt
early chair of the police Federation he
was out on a night shift in Southampton
he tweeted to say that he dealt with
happy drunks angry drunks fights and
more angry drunks and then he said what
was crystal-clear is that drunk people
can't / won't socially distance now we
know that the rate of infection the r8
is creeping up it could even be above
one in London is it really a sensible
thing to reopen pubs
yes and of course there's there's
incidents like the one that you just
described and we've seen that throughout
that they've been individual incidents
that have been very unhelpful and but
the large proportion of people the vast
majority of people are I think doing the
right thing and they are you know
increasingly people are able to use the
freedoms that we're restoring you know I
had my hair cut yesterday and I'm very
relieved about it and but also doing
that responsibly and I think the police
have done an absolutely fantastic job
throughout this crisis really really
difficult job and
and the same again last night when the
vast majority of people followed the
rules did the right thing and of course
will take action when we need to when
where if the minority break the rules
is it ok though if the vast majority
obey the rules because even a minority
we know with this virus can cause
infection rates to go up quite
dramatically well will of course keep
this very closely under review and you
know you've seen for instance in
Leicester but also in other places that
we don't shirk from bringing in more
drastic measures if that's what's needed
to control the virus but the overall
plan has always been through this
lifting of the lockdown to try to lift
the national measures but also be
absolutely crystal clear that will
tackle local flare-ups when we see them
and we've seen that in a number of
places and we've taken either we've
taken targeted action and targeted
measures and then if that hasn't worked
we're fully prepared to take the action
like like that that we took in in
Leicester but you know at the same time
we've got to try to move to a a more
more more close to normal where people
can do the things that they love and and
and that's been our our plan all along
and my overriding message to people is
yes enjoy the new freedoms but do so
safely following social distancing it is
so important and even the basics like
washing your hands we have got this
virus getting right under control the
number of new infections is under 600 on
the last data so it's really coming down
in terms of the number of positive cases
that we're finding and that's good news
but we just got to stick have the
resilience and the resolve to stick at
it
and to be very careful in how we enjoy
those those new freedoms because with
the numbers do show that's a
significantly higher rate for infection
in Leicester than elsewhere which is of
course it's why they've seen this lock
down our clothing factories where there
appears to have been pretty poor social
distancing to blame for that well we are
very worried about the about the number
of infections in Leicester and clearly
very high three times higher than the
next highest City in terms of the the
testing results as you know we put more
testing in but that doesn't account for
the increases the increases over and
above that which would have been
accounted for by the increase in testing
we've seen rates
well we've seen outbreaks in food
factories and in clothing factories
there's some quite significant concerns
about some of the employment practices
in some of the clothing factories in
Leicester they are important problems to
deal with
but the number one problem that we've
got to deal with is getting this virus
under control and so we've put in a huge
amount of extra resource into Leicester
working with the local council and the
teamwork there it is this last week has
been has been very effective and I hope
that we see the results of that come
through in the in the numbers and the
and the testing in as soon as possible
it does seem to mean it can't really
separate at the bringing the virus under
control with the Employment Practices it
feels like they could be pretty
significantly linked and what I don't
understand is you know we all abided by
this very strict lockdown in our
personal lives and yet employers we're
effectively just given guidance on what
to do if I'm looking at for example the
guidance from the government on this it
just says you know employers should
decide in consultation with their
workers whether it's viable for them to
continue working from home where it's
decided that workers should come in to
their place of work then this will need
to be reflected in the risk assessment
and actions taken to manage the risks of
transmission in line with this guidance
I mean I can't help think of it this
sounds quite weak the good employers
will do the right thing the bad
employers will just ignore it and this
matters not just for the people who work
in these
conditions but for the rest of us - yes
the the thing is though Sophie that that
guidance is statutory guidance it's
backed up by health and safety
legislation and there are very
significant fines that are that can be
levied if it's broken furthermore we can
well or also what we're doing at the
moment instead is you can also have the
authority to be able to shut down a
business if it doesn't follow that
guidance so there's significant Forsman
yes and that's happened absolutely
normally it's happened in consultation
where than working with the with the
employer with the business in question
but we do have that power
absolutely so the guidance is not you
know it's we're not just asking nicely
we're very clear to businesses that
these are their responsibilities for
instance the same goes for the
responsibility for hospitality
businesses to to take the names and the
numbers of the people who who are there
so that we can do contact tracing if
that's necessary so some people might be
wondering if this is all a bit too late
though you know you can impose fines you
can shut down businesses after the
problem has already happened and for
many people looking what's happened at
Leicester they may be wondering if you
were just too slow to act anyway on the
lock down the prime minister said that
the government first took notice of an
issue in Leicester on the 8th of June
you spoke about it at the press
conference on the 18th of June but the
lockdown wasn't imposed until Monday the
29th of June why'd it take so long well
we were acting right from the start when
we first saw and you know in other parts
of the country the early action targeted
action that we took was successful for
instance in in cochis is a good example
where we where we did close some
factories and also in other parts of the
country and in Leicester we took the
same sort of action we put in the extra
mobile testing units and we work with
the council
that wasn't effective it was clear that
the outbreak was wider in the community
and that's why we had to take the firmer
action but in your question you said and
you know why do you why do you wait to
see that there's a problem before you
shut the businesses well of course we
have to follow the data you have to see
where the virus is and where it's
spreading and that and take the action
to to tackle that outbreak this is
exactly how the next phase of this this
control of the virus is expected to play
out we explained in advance as we
release the lockdown
the national lockdown measures that the
next phase would be all about local
action local lockdowns whether that's an
individual GP surgery or shutting a
hospital to new admissions or a factory
just as we were talking about or then
much more significant citywide action
and this is this having the tools to be
able to take that very targeted action
when we see an outbreak is there so that
we can then release the measures on
everybody else and and have a much more
targeted approach and it's it is clear
that that it is that plan is working the
question that I was trying to get to the
point I was trying to get to is whether
or not you take in too much of a soft
messaging around businesses from the
very beginning talking about guidelines
talking about consultations rather than
the more forceful message that you could
argue that you take in with people
sunbathing or sitting down in parks now
you've always said that you know there
will be a time to learn the lessons from
a coronavirus but now isn't the right
time this could be one of those lessons
I just wonder if you know when would be
the right time to start learning lessons
we've got fears of a second spike coming
potentially in the winter as well what
are the lessons we need to learn now to
make sure that we're prepared for when
and if that happens well we are Lester
we're learning all of that all of the
time looking at what works
needs improvement and so for for
instance you know in the last fortnight
we've made sure that we've got the data
on testing results out to local
authorities so all local authorities now
have that data and if they need support
in interpreting it then they can come to
us and ask for that support making sure
the question you asked about shutting
down businesses is a is an important one
but of course you have to do this
working working with an employer because
the many steps that you can take before
you fully close a factory to make sure
you isolate the people who either have
the virus or have been at risk of it but
I've come back to the central point in
your question which is about the the
messaging to people watching this
program about what to do this summer and
the central point is this yes go out
there and enjoy summer and get out and
enjoy the things that that we love that
we've been able to lift the restrictions
on but do so safely and there are two
parts to that there are two parts enjoy
summer safely and that's it's a really
important message and I think it's one
that the vast majority of people
understand now it's of course the NHS's
birthday today 72nd birthday one of the
most challenging periods it feels that
the NHS has ever gone through The
Observer is reporting that NHS England
has asked the Treasury for 10 billion
pounds to help cover some of those
expect costs of coronavirus but they're
nowhere near in agreement and is that
something that the Treasury should grant
NHS England given these exceptional
circumstances well I just don't
recognise that story we've been working
very closely with the Treasury on making
sure we have the funding that we need
whether it's for for PPE or for the
extra support that's needed in hospitals
offer the Nightingale project or for the
use of the independent sector we have a
we have an enormous amount of support
from the
I'm incredibly great well we've been
working throughout this to put literally
record sums into the NHS the Treasury
have worked alongside us
they've been brilliant throughout it in
terms of you know we have at Pace needed
very significant extra funding that
they're put in just last week the Prime
Minister announced another one and a
half billion pounds for the for the NHS
that will be to expand our a and E's for
this winter because with social
distancing the many a and E's across the
country are going to need to be bigger
it's also for for maintenance which is
much needed and to get on with catechol
projects so it the Treasury have been
we've been working hand in glove with
them throughout this well rather than a
few minutes clapping that we've seen of
course with the best birthday present
for the NHS be a pay rise for some of
its lower paid staff what we absolutely
want to want to rot what a reward NHS
staff for what they've done
I mean it on this 72nd anniversary we
should remember that this has been the
toughest year in the NHS is 72 year
history and the the lengths that NHS
staff have gone to have been incredible
but also the flexibility that they've
shown the the amazing increase for
instance in the use of technology which
has improved many of the services and
the the ability of people to step up
when it was really needed and take on
decision-making so there's a there's
many things that we want to bottle from
the good things the NHS has done in
response to this crisis you know putting
up the Nightingale hospitals in nine
days it normally takes nine years to
build an NHS hospital and we did those
in nine days so there's there's a lot of
really good things that the NHS has done
that we really want to to bottle and
learn from from the future okay know
your news there on whether a pay rise is
going to be forthcoming now I hate these
questions because I know you're not
going to give me anything or give me
very little but of course we're
expecting the mini budget if you like
from the chancellor wish
soon ACK next week lots of focus on jobs
of course has lots of rumors about our
potential apprenticeships V 80-something
stamp duty maybe is there anything that
you can give us for what we can expect
from next week no you know the I think
the way that we put an economic package
together both in the heat of the crisis
with the furlough scheme it's been one
of the most generous responses in the
world and then with the Prime Minister's
speech last week a very significant
investment but also critically a
direction of travel which is that we now
is the moment to invest and to deal with
some of the long-standing problems for
instance under investment in transport
and the need to deal with some of the
some of the areas of the NHS that we're
putting money into and so we have
alongside the health response had a very
very significant economic response and
you'll get more news on that from the
Chancellor on Wednesday on that economic
response because we'll see a little
later in the program I went to
Birmingham this week to have a look at
some of the sectors that are being
particularly hit by this and what's
pretty clear is that not all sectors
have been here equally so you know
hospitality retail these kind of sectors
are facing a real uphill battle often
women working in those sectors and yet
the Prime Minister's announcement last
week was seem to be centering around
jobs in infrastructure in build build
build are you actually really lining up
the jobs where they are needed in the
investment where it's needed or you just
kind of always using old solutions -
what's a very new unprecedented problem
no I think that that's that it's the
wrong way around if anything in that
there are some long-standing areas that
we need more investment in and this is
what the Prime Minister's speech was
focused on and there are but also the
amount of support that we've put into
those areas that are particularly hard
here you mentioned hospitality
you know which has only been able to
start getting and going again yesterday
and the the amount of support that we
put in during the crisis has been
unprecedented
so there's been support across the board
but you know I know and coming from a
small business background myself I know
how much of an impact this has had on
our on businesses and on small
businesses in particular and the sense
of you know something completely out of
the balloon knocking your your business
over is a real sense of injustice I
understand that and we won't be able to
save every business but we have been
able to put in an unprecedented package
and I I think that the Chancellor and
prime minister who've obviously led the
charge on on that side I think they've
done a very very good job in putting
together the best possible support
package but they're clearly who needs to
be more and we respond to circumstances
and hence on Wednesday what you'll hear
from the Chancellor is a package focused
on jobs jobs jobs so that we can get
this the economic recovery from this
virus as fast as we can whilst also
keeping in place the action that's
needed to deal with the virus and to
keep the virus right down now we are
running out of time but there's one
quite important story that I do want to
ask you about in many of the papers
today on the Chinese turkle's John
Huawei now there are reports that
ministers are going to start phasing out
its involvement in the UK's 5g network
after security concerns raised in a
report by GCHQ I mean that would be a
pretty significant u-turn from the
government is it true
well I wouldn't comment on on leaks of
that kind what I can say though is that
when we came out within an interim
report on this earlier in the year there
were a number of conditions that needed
to be met and so I'm sure that the
National Security Council will look at
those conditions and make the right
decision on on this to make sure that we
have both a very strong and telecoms
infrastructure and everyone can get a
phone signal but also that it is secure
and that the British government can have
confidence at the date is secure so if
first say there are concerns well I'm
not going to say anymore I'm not going
to get into any more details than that
other than to say that you know we have
been looking very closely at this and if
you look at the report earlier in this
student this year there were certain
conditions in that and I'm sure that the
culture secretary who's responsible for
this area will will come forward if
there's any more detail I can't resist
asking the final question and we've
heard that Kanye West is going to be
running for president do you think he'd
make a good president of the United
States it's the first I've heard of it I
think I respect them the office of the
President of the United States now
support a support what is our very our
strongest and closest ally and no matter
who their president is so you could
definitely do business in Kanye West
them look I'm absolutely not going to
get involved in the u.s. presidential
election we've I'm concentrating on the
the running of this country what I will
say is that we absolutely support our
relationship with America and no matter
who the occupant of the of the Oval
Office is very diplomatic thank you very
much for being on the program this
morning thank you